have you guys seen squid game yet dude
that show is amazing i just finished it
last night oh my god i'm not gonna spoil
anything but that show is phenomenal if
you're one of the people i don't know
anybody who hasn't but if you're one of
the people who hasn't even seen or heard
of that show it's like the most popular
show in the world right now
you need to watch it that show's amazing
okay so let's talk about the season
finale
of what if right
uh
i got mixed feelings about this man you
know we'll talk about the ending here in
a minute but i got mixed feelings about
this um it was cool to see a lot of that
stuff in all honesty it just kind of
felt like a what if meets multiversal
version of like avengers right a coming
together of these different superheroes
who were basically the most popular
versions of the avengers roster minus
like hawkeye and a few other people
basically all the characters that we saw
over the course of the show teaming up
to defeat ultron who had the infinity
stones
cool right i mean there's there's not a
whole lot going on there right i mean it
was a cool battle and i will say ultron
with the infinity stones is probably the
coolest that we've ever seen here's a
funny thing and it's something that a
lot of people have been talking about
since the ending of last week's episode
thanos was an idiot and i've kind of
been saying that for a while
really more to myself than i have
anybody else but in all honesty thanos
was kind of a [ __ ] right like here are
these stones they can basically grant a
person seemingly the ability to do
anything they want to and thanos is like
i'm going to blink out half the life in
the universe because there's just too
many people for the universe of support
right not enough resources well good job
thanos you idiot unless you sterilize
the other half of the universe then all
that's gonna happen is in like a hundred
years or a thousand years things are
gonna be right back to where they were
before so cool you kind of managed to
hold things off for a little bit
he kicked the can down the road it's
basically what he did ultron with the
infinity stones that was phenomenal that
was cool and that's how i felt like
infinity stones should be used right it
was one thing to see him face off
against the watcher right at the really
the second half of the episode of last
week it's a whole nother to see how it
was used here right to see it used in
that way it was amazing i love seeing
the battles the conflicts it really begs
the question what chance did any of
these heroes have against ultron in the
first place i do feel like they
underused doctor strange right that
version of doctor strange with all those
demonic powers i feel like he could have
been a lot more prominent there i feel
like there could have been a lot more
that he offered aside from just putting
them in these kind of cocoons that kept
them safe from the power of the infinity
stones the fact that he was able to do
that and then also protect them from the
infinity stones at the same time really
seemed like he could have brought a lot
more to the table than he did now a lot
of this is probably just due to the
writing and the fact that they wanted to
create a kind of ensemble which is not
uncommon in marvel comics it happens all
the time perfect example of this is a
kid named franklin richards this kid has
the ability to alter reality on a
universal scale but you almost never see
him in any major conflict and the reason
why is because if he was there the
question fans would ask is why isn't he
fixing everything right now this was
never really an issue until you got to
hickman's run when hickman's run came in
that's when the mental blocks that reed
richards had put in his son's mind had
basically been removed and franklin had
really access to the full totality of
his powers that happened when he
basically ended up meeting the older
version of himself prior to that you
could make that argument right well
franklin doesn't access all his power so
you doesn't there he can be here it's
fine you can't really save the day
nowadays we can't do that and so it
makes sense that with this kind of a
situation with the power that doctor
strange had having absorbed all those
demonic beings that they kind of reduce
his his involvement here a little bit to
where he was more of like a defensive
measure as opposed to an offensive
measure that being said
if he was more of an offensive measure i
think the episode could have been longer
and i think the battle could have been a
lot better because the reality is as
cool as some of those characters are
what can black panther or eric
killmonger or captain carter or black
widow what could they really bring to a
conflict to a to a battle involving a
highly intellectual
artificial intelligence
in possession of the infinity stones
that has full understanding of the
multiverse they really couldn't bring
anything there so the battle kind of
stretched the limits of credulity which
is also something that i do want to kind
of point out here i do kind of like the
idea that black widow went to an
alternate reality where she had
previously died and now they have their
own black widow black widow being
somewhere is not going to change
anything right like i mean she can shoot
really well and she can punch hard but
it's black widow man like when has black
widow ever turned the tide of anything
like believably i mean i don't hate
black widow i just kind of recognize the
role that black widow plays in the
bigger picture now if he had sent like
that version of doctor strange there
yeah like that would have been enough
but like black widow come on man i mean
whatever dude so in any event the whole
thing about this is and what i really
loved here and i think this is really
the icing on the cake and probably one
of the best decisions they could have
made that they didn't spend enough time
focusing on
eric killmonger i love that as soon as
he picked up the head of that version of
ultron you knew something was gonna
happen right i mean you knew something's
gonna happen because that dude just
can't be trusted right he's been
villainous pretty much since we saw him
right like from the time he first met
tony stark in his story it's kind of
okay this guy's kind of a villain and i
love that they kept that what i did love
was the idea is he took the armor of
ultron bonded it to himself and then
took the infinity stones right i loved
that what i didn't love is it lasted
that long and it should have lasted much
longer than that
i would love to have seen what someone
like eric killmonger could do with
infinity stones not only that he
actually made this incredibly compelling
case where he's like we can use the
stones to fix our own universes we can
use them to make everything back to the
way that they're supposed to be now
whether or not he would actually allow
that to happen i'm not entirely sure but
honestly i would have gone for it i
would have been like
okay cool i'm on board man you got my
vote at the very least so even if the
guys say no come to my universe and fix
it right you set everything back to
normal and everything will be cool right
i would have taken that i did love that
from killmonger and it was almost kind
of like they were toying with this idea
of like the humanity of killmonger right
that like even if only for a moment he
was kind of being a good guy having said
that with regards to the overall feel of
this episode
i think there were a lot of wasted
moments here i think that there are some
things that could have happened in this
episode that would have been colossal
and the reason why is because as cool as
this was and as interesting as the what
if series was this is one of those
instances where when you're in for a
penny you're in for a pound if you're
going to have a finality that's given in
this story that's going to have all
these heroes team up against ultron it
needs to kind of leave us wanting more
and i don't mean some mid-credit scene
where like the hydra stomper is
discovered and like captain carter gets
back steve rogers that doesn't matter
what i'm talking about is stakes
significance the idea that this will
carry on into something else here's one
of the things that i kind of expected to
see going into this or at least once we
got to the tail end of this right for
the most part you didn't really see the
watcher like when you saw the guardians
facing off against ultron you didn't
really see the watcher there and i felt
like that was a huge missed opportunity
and here's the reason why so going back
to the infinity gauntlet story on mobile
comics for a second bear with me here
going back to the story it was basically
all this kind of a a scheme that was
thought up by adam warlock not really
thanos getting the infinity stones but
the battle itself so the way this played
out is that adam warlock had basically
gone to the cosmic entities and sought a
trial with the living tribunal and he
pleaded his case the other cosmic
entities did too but basically saying
thanos having the infinity stones is an
imbalance of magical energy within the
universe itself it destabilizes the
hierarchy the response of the tribunal
was no right thanos attaining the
infinity stones basically means thanos
is attaining a kind of power that is
native to this universe he didn't bring
in a source of energy from an alternate
reality he's using what this universe
already provides and you eternity if you
are not powerful enough to maintain your
role and thanos takes that from you that
is simply the weak being moved aside to
make way for the strong so ultimately
the living tribunal chose not to act and
so what you got was adam warlock
assembling a whole bunch of different
heroes and basically it was designed to
be a ruse the whole idea behind this is
the heroes would fight thanos and they
would just get crushed right that was
the expectation is they would all get
destroyed but during that time thanos
would become arrogant he'd get carried
away with the power that he had and in a
brief moment of weakness or of a lack of
thought it would allow adam warlock to
make his move and so keeping silver
surfer at his side because silver surfer
was the fastest being in the universe at
the time there's a point when thanos
goes to to launch a punch and the silver
surfer races in and out of warlock's
direction as fast as he can to steal the
gauntlet and it doesn't work now of
course thanos with the infinity gauntlet
plays no real involvement in the story
whatsoever at least in this episode but
the point being that you could have had
an instance where the watcher basically
sought uh sought a trial with a living
tribunal and asked the living tribunal
for aid and in this instance the
tribunal would most likely say yes and
the tribunal himself would step in and
then basically end up bringing the event
to an end with with ultra now would that
take away from the idea of like the
guardians of the multiverse saving the
day sure but at the end of the day it
wouldn't really take away from the
overall episode we wouldn't really walk
away from that well this whole battle
was lackluster we'd walk away from it
like yeah
the living tribunal right we'd be super
excited it'd be amazing
so we would have absolutely loved it
even if the tribunal stepped in and just
in one fell swoop into the whole thing
one it would have showed us the tribunal
exists and two it would have given us
even if only on a very small level a
glimpse of his power that like he just
snaps his fingers and the gauntlet shuts
down right all the all the infinity
stones are done and that's it and he's
just like like this is done right go
back to your universe while we'll wipe
you out right ultron decides to
challenge him tribunal destroys ultron
day is saved everything goes back to
normal they asked the watcher what the
hell do you want what was that guy he's
like well there's forces out there
beyond your ability to imagine or
whatever and it kind of gives us a
little bit of a taster for the fact that
we could see some kind of expansion on
that in doctor strange too or in the
future what if seasons beyond that even
if we didn't invoke the idea of the
tribunal we could have seen kane the
conqueror here in the sense that as like
a mid-credit scene while it's all going
down and ultron's being defeated you
have came the conqueror in the far-flung
future watching everything unfold
possibly preparing to act but then
realizing he doesn't need to because
ultron's going to be defeated anyway
because he knows how things are going to
play out again these are only a couple
of ideas but i feel like these were
hugely missed opportunities in the what
if series because in all honesty given
the fact that the whole thing was
self-contained given the idea that we
saw all these different alternate
reality versions of characters all of
whom were brought together on a singular
team to defeat some alternate version of
ultron vision merging whatever who ended
up capturing the infinity stones and the
fact that it was all just sort of done
basically kind of gives me this idea or
this belief that as cool as the what if
series is
it doesn't really matter nothing that
took place here matters has any
involvement or significance whatsoever
even if if like a mid-credit scene or a
post-credit scene that version of doctor
strange in his own prison escapes to the
main marvel universe and then there's
your theory about how doctor strange in
the mcu is not actually the doctor
strange that we know it's a different
version which is the one from the what
if right doesn't have to be that exact
same thing but nothing from this show
really carries on into the rest of the
mcu in any real meaningful way and
that's the thing that kind of brings me
down a little bit because i feel like
this was just a golden opportunity to
one expand on the multiverse and two
give us something that carries on into
the future of the multiverse now it
could just be the what if series in and
of itself will always be standalone
it'll never be tied to anything it's
part of the greater mcu beyond what we
see in the episodes that we get but i
really hope that's not the case i would
like to have seen something carry over
into the future of the marvel cinematic
universe especially now that we're
dealing with the multiverse having said
that do i believe that the entire world
of series was bad no it was amazing it
was fun
it was some of the most fun i've had
watching a marvel tv show for quite some
time were there some lulls were there
some episodes that were kind of like
yeah i mean sure yeah definitely but
were there also episodes that were
fantastic and phenomenal and in a lot of
ways are comparable to if not better
than some of the mcu movies yeah
absolutely the doctor strange episode
and the ultron episode are two right i
mean those were better than some of the
mcu movies that we've gotten and those
episodes were 30 minutes long so i loved
what we got i love the idea behind it i
definitely want to see more of it
especially with characters that will be
introduced later on down the line
characters that have already been
introduced and they want to give them a
bigger stage to operate on somebody like
monica rambo who we saw in one division
possibly white vision or maybe even new
characters like adam brashear or
something like that some kind of a cameo
that'll go on to kind of lead to
something bigger in the mcu whatever it
is i enjoyed the series i thought it was
fun it's just at the end of the day i
feel like they had some some hugely
missed opportunities things they could
have done massive things with that
really would have just kind of exploded
the show left us some one hell of a
cliffhanger and then in turn given us
something to look forward to in the
future of the mcu with that being said
guys let me know what you think down in
the comments section did you guys enjoy
what if did you think it was kind of
like
it's whatever let me know what you guys
think thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace